welcome back to un sensor Canadian
female power lifter April Hutchinson's
been suspended from the sport for 2
years we taking a speaking we speaking
out actually on this show about trans
athletes competing in the sport
powerlifting Union news comment she made
against her rival transgender record
breaking powerlifter an Andre's right
here on uncensored as part of the
reasoning for the suspension here's what
she said apparently was so
awful so he is a 40 40y old uh 6' 200
50b man well that National Record that
he broke athletes have been chasing that
for years so he just goes to show the
advantages the phys physiological
advantages that a male has over a female
well April joins me now April first of
all I'm apped that you've been suspended
and I'm even more apped that you've been
suspended for stating what appears to be
a simple fact you were talking about the
fact that a biological male who
identifies now as a woman and is a trans
athlete um was getting an unfair
Advantage because of their physiology
over you for stating the bleeding
obvious you're the one now who can't
compete yeah exactly uh I guess saying
uh truth and fact calling uh Andress AB
biological male is considered hate
speech and goes against their social
media um code um when talking about
sports Pierce you would know this you
have to State what the person is so I I
was actually thinking I was being polite
saying a biological male um and I was in
fact saying the truth so uh bodies play
sports not identities so when we're
talking about sports especially
powerlifting a strength sport you need
to say call a man a man call a woman a
woman right because physiology I'm
afraid is physiology there's nothing you
get away from it um it just seems
completely ridiculous to me that for
calling this out this this shock
shocking unfairness towards women born
with female bodies in women's sport you
can now not compete I mean it's it how
do you feel about
this I I'm actually I mean this was a
week ago that I found out um I was
sitting there on the couch I opened the
email from the Ethics Committee I was
blown away 2-year suspension is very
harsh it's a it's a a suspension you
would give someone that got caught for
doping put it that way so so I mean
everyone's still shocked about it I'm
I'm very upset I'm very hurt by my
Federation and I do feel that this
suspension was issued let alone focusing
on my terminology to deviate from the
real Topic at hand which is unfairness
in sports yeah I mean you know I saw
Megan rapino the football player soccer
of course over in America um who has
just retired and right at the moment of
her retirement she said oh what I'd
really want is to see trans
uh women playing in the uh US Women's
National Soccer Team which is great
because it means her plays won't get
taken and my response would be okay so
what happens if Lionel Messi who's
playing in the MLS in America what
happens if he decides to identify as a
woman a he can if he wants to B there'
be no law against him prohibiting him
from playing for the American women's
national team is that the way we're
going to go where lonel Messi suddenly
says I'm a woman and breaks even more
record but makes it irrevocably
impossible for an actual woman to
compete um that is where this is going
if we're not very careful isn't
it oh it's true and you said it uh
Pierce uh it doesn't affect rapino
anymore so have fun virtual singling you
know that's exactly what she's doing um
and if like for my sport it affects many
lifters I know four lifters off the top
of my head that will be competing
against and coming up and that have a
problem with it that have actually
written the Federation two people have
dropped out one person cut weight so
they don't have to compete against an
it's not consensual and I mean it only
takes one person to not consent and the
federations that are allowing this you
know it's it's disgraceful it is
disgusting that they're allowing this to
happen yeah I mean it's basically
licensed cheating is what it is and it's
like saying that certain comp
competitors can dope you know that was
the case everyone would be up in arms
and saying well it's unfair because you
get an advantage this is unfair you get
an advantage I mean there's another
story over here which I know you're
aware of um which has really just
staggered me a health charity in the UK
that helps women specifically suffering
from
endometriosis which is a a condition
about the lining of a womb has now
appointed as his chief executive a
transwoman so a biological male what do
you think of
that
I I heard that and I mean what a huge
insult to women you know I went for a
test the other day I went for my first
mamogram and you know I was just sitting
there thinking like how would I feel if
there was a a man in there with me um
you know it's it's a very private issue
um even just going into locker rooms
women are very private like I'm always
covering myself up and that's in front
of women so you take something like so
private like a health condition and you
appoint a man in in charge a huge slap
to women's faces yeah is it's nuts isn't
it um April are you going to appeal
against your
suspension yes the first step I have a
great lawyer um uh Lisa buildy is my
lawyer we will be appealing it we do
have 10 days and then after that we will
be pursuing other legal Avenues which I
can't announce right now but uh we will
be uh seeking legal action well I'm very
sorry again that it's come to this and
that this show has played a part of this
ridiculous suspension I wish you luot
with the appeal we'll follow it we'll
keep in touch and I wish you all the
best thank you so much for having me
again good to see
you